[Music]
[Applause]
a Conan O'Brien here the video blog and
I'm in my room and here's what's going
on in my world been up to a lot of cool
stuff hey today I invented a new snack I
took some crumbs from a bag of Cheetos
and I blended them into a milk shape and
I call it a Frappuccino
I haven't haven't tried it yet because
it smells like a diaper Oh
also I have a new fun game where
whenever I see the name of a movie that
I I like to say more like after the
movie title and then change the movie
title to something crappy it's pretty
cool I'll show you how it works it goes
like this I go like huh it's pretty cool
I go Moneyball more like money boring
Dolphin Tale more like dolphin fail I
don't know how she does it
more like I don't care how
[Applause]
abduction I didn't think of one for
abduction
okay here's the new segment to cheer
everybody up something I came up with
called yawning animals with people's
voices yawning animals with people
noises this is where I take videos of
animals yawning and replace the sound
with people's voices it's really cool
[Music]
[Applause]
so anyway I was watching toddlers and
tiaras yeah it's not a one what
abduction
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]